hola bienvenidos a migrantes el programa
semanal de france 24 sobre el éxodo
[Música]
la migración hacia eeuu ocupa un lugar
crucial en la carrera por la presidencia
del país y continuará dentro de la
agenda política del nuevo gobierno sin
importar si los estadounidenses votan
por la continuidad o el cambio la
atención durante las campañas se centra
en estados considerados indecisos
uno de ellos arizona es fronterizo y
allí la migración se vive de cerca hace
apenas cuatro meses el presidente de
trump visitaba ese estado donde
informaba sobre la construcción de 322
kilómetros más del muro una barrera
física que no solo separa a dos países
sino que es muestra evidente de la
política migratoria de la unión
americana bajo la actual administración
que pasa hoy en la zona veámoslo en el
siguiente informe
marta y juan son esposos pero su vida
juntos está en pausa la única forma de
verse ahora es a través del muro
fronterizo que en este punto separa a
nogales en arizona ya la ciudad homónima
en mexico
marta fue deportada hace dos años junto
a su hijo y ahora espera una cita con
las autoridades de inmigración en ciudad
juárez
ella es mi esposa condujo 12 horas de
sinaloa solo para que yo pudiera ver a
mi hijo por dos días tres hace cinco
meses que no lo veía juan es
estadounidense y siente las
consecuencias de que su familia esté
lejos es como si no hubiera perdido su
primera palabra me perdí la primera vez
que camino me perdí su primer diente me
perdí todo destruido no tuve la
oportunidad de verlo de experimentarlo
este es mi primer bebé sabes y nosotros
queríamos experimentar ese buen momento
ese buen sentimiento de piel aunque
nunca ha votado lo hará en estas
elecciones de eeuu con la esperanza de
que algo cambie
pero como es vivir con el muro de fondo
para los residentes del lado
estadounidense de la frontera muy poco
ha cambiado desde que asumió la
presidencia a bordo ni beso tenencia que
si éste lo único que se puede ver es el
alambre de púas en la parte superior de
la valla pero eso no ha hecho gran
diferencia todavía hay gente saltando
gente pasando por los túneles
aún hay movimiento cada noche no está
muy verde venga es eric no votará en
esta elección
quien sí lo hará es post man y elegirá
la continuidad
creo que va a haber más seguridad más
trabajo se hace en el muro en la
frontera vamos a conseguir más trabajos
eso es lo que creemos
pero para francis glass mucho ha
cambiado desde 2016 y para peor cuidad o
por olvidar fence for many years
hemos tenido una frontera hemos tenido
una valla durante muchos años pero ha
habido un cambio necesario y limpio hoy
no puedo necesariamente señalar el
cambio sólo que antes de que él
estuviera aquí solía ser más fácil para
la gente ir y volver en comeback y no
teníamos visitantes mexicanos santis
turistas hombres de negocios y viceversa
el vice versa mientras los indecisos
barajan por quién votar en los comicios
y lo cierto es que el muro que tienen
como vecino seguirá siendo protagonista
en el próximo gobierno
y tanto la política como la migración
son temas que dividen en california una
pareja que ha trabajado por más de dos
décadas a favor de los migrantes no
coinciden sus posturas los aleja la
política pero los une su interés por
salvar vidas en el desierto
desde hace 21 años john y su esposa
laura ubican estaciones de agua a lo
largo del desierto un paso obligado para
miles de migrantes que cruzan la
frontera por el sur de california
hoy recoger algunas de las provisiones
que dejaron en meses pasados ante la
proximidad del invierno agua que ha
servido de oasis para los inmigrantes y
ha reducido las muertes por
deshidratación y agotamiento
en el año 2000 hubo un montón de muertes
en el desierto estaban muriendo por
deshidratación esto pasó en ese sector
ese verano murieron 29 personas en unos
tres meses así que leí sobre ello en los
periódicos y entonces traté de ayudar a
mi hermano a hacer algunas cosas en los
90 que no fueron efectivas entonces
pensamos sólo sacaremos un poco de
nuestra agua de la mía y la de mis hijos
ya se lo hicimos saber a esta pareja la
unne el servicio pero la divide la
política en los últimos cuatro años su
relación ha estado a prueba
ama tema kraft mayonnaise cerró y
publican soy demócrata en el pozo de
republicanos y creo que esto ha creado
un poco de fricción entre nosotros
porque no me gusta trabajar
trump me gusta la forma en la que está
demonizando a la gente especialmente a
la gente pobre que viene de diferentes
partes del arte laura nacido en méxico
rechaza las políticas anti inmigrantes
del actual gobierno
jon sigue la línea de los republicanos
pero entiende las razones de los que
emigran
yo nací aquí tuve la suerte de nacer en
eeuu donde tenemos gran libertad grandes
oportunidades los chicos del sur no
tienen las mismas oportunidades sólo
porque su sistema es diferente así que
si yo fuera uno de ellos también vendría
al norte haría lo mismo en zenten john
admite que no voto por trauma en 2016
por respeto a su esposa y a la misión
que cumple un proyecto que no dejará de
lado pese a lo que pasa en política
mientras el tema migratorio seduce a
distancia de lectores lo cierto es que
miles esperan a ser real el tan anhelado
sueño americano y el dato de migración
de la semana
eeuu recibirá 15.000 refugiados durante
el año fiscal 2000 21 se trata de la
cuota más baja de la historia que esta
vez incluye además a un máximo de 1.000
cupos para procedentes de el salvador
guatemala y honduras hasta que
inmigrantes de france 24 los invitamos a
comentar en nuestras redes sociales con
el hashtag migrantes f24 siga conectados
con más información en france 24 y
france 24 puntocom
[Música]